uh with everything costing more how
about this how about getting your
groceries for free probably sounds
pretty good out there to a lot of
shoppers because the labor department is
telling us that food inflation soared
more than 12
last month compared to a year ago
so in answer to that this morning we're
going to introduce you to a woman who is
inspiring millions to learn how to eat
for free how by foraging for food in the
wild yeah it's a growing trend and jamie
yuka's got a first-hand look at how to
find food and how to cook that food with
the help of this james beard award
winner and tick-tock star there she is
yum
in the woods near her home in columbus
ohio alexis nicole nelson she's gonna
take a couple of these is foraging for
edible plants violet leaves
she's also feeding her soul
there is something that just puts a
smile on my face it gets my heart racing
these guys completely edible the little
bulbs are sweet
i always feel like the tips of them are
kind of asparagus adjacent yeah they are
mm-hmm i feel so connected to my
surroundings we have some cut leaf tooth
wart in here nelson invited me to join
her for a walk on the wild side so here
you can see that they look very garlic
scapy our adventure began in a local
park
free onions free onions
for the low low price of spending time
outside
next stop i do actually forage here a
cemetery dating back to the 1700s these
belong to the black locust tree
where some people see weeds or swamps
nelson sees a supermarket
so sweet so sweet did you know maple
seeds are edible there's a little bit of
nectar in here waiting for you she's
turned her passion into her profession
very torn about whether to candy these
or make them savory what do you think i
should do sharing her adventures and
recipes on tick tock with millions now
they're roasty toasty let's try some
i say happy snacking don't die at the
end of most of my videos mostly ingest
but also like seriously don't die
because you can i will love you forever
everyone at home if you don't die
i don't put in a bowl
i just eat it as i go foraging expert
samuel thayer is nelson's mentor and the
author of several guidebooks if you're a
foodie there's flavors you cannot buy
and it's really fun i can't imagine why
it's taken so long for it to catch on
it's called alligator weed he's seen
interest in foraging surge since the
pandemic emptied store shelves and drove
people outdoors
thayer hosts plant walks around the
country like this one in north carolina
what's it like for you to take a newbie
out with you it doesn't take long for me
to really surprise somebody because they
might be afraid it's not going to taste
good and then i give them something and
they're like whoa that is good their
eyes open wide and their ears perk up
and they're following me they're eager
for the next plant spicy smart weed
for nelson foraging takes on deeper
meaning it's a way to connect with her
father's indigenous ancestry and
confront a history of systemic racism in
america's national parks which were
segregated until the mid-1940s
to avoid trouble in natural spaces
nelson says she dresses to appear as
approachable as possible no one's going
to look and be like ah yes the girl in
the cotton candy dress i feel like she
means trouble have you had the cops
called on you before i've had the cops
come up to me before asking what i'm
doing after other people were curious
about it i also love an oversized hoodie
but that's not gonna be what you find me
out here in for sure
because of that fear factor because of
that fear factor yeah
look at all of this chicken of the woods
it's really easy to climb a tree in a
dress that's all i'm going to say you
don't have to worry about pants
splitting when you're climbing a tree in
a dress
[Music]
and if you give them a smell back home
in nelson's kitchen
we're going to be making black locust
beignets
with our collection of edibles and
shelves resembling a mad scientist lab
she began to whip up an all-veggie feast
you go out and you get what you get and
then you gotta think of what you're
gonna make with it all once you get home
it kind of makes
life like a competition cooking show i
like that
the final touch a drizzle of pinecone
jam okay i'm going in for the pine cone
and while i was skeptical at first one
bite it's a flavor explosion that's
delicious
give me more pine cones okay
i was sold nelson hopes you will be too
i just hope we're raising up a
generation of people who regardless of
what they they look like or what their
background is everyone feels entitled to
the outdoors if that's a place you want
to be for cbs mornings i'm jamie yukas
in columbus ohio
[Music]
i love this woman i love her too she is
so unapologetically herself she loves
being outdoors i love her spirit her
passion her hair i also would love to
know what gayle thinks of foraging in
the wild
i'm gonna have to ask we will have to
ask her she's probably watching but i do
think that what she said was so you know
the low low price of just being outdoors
sometimes we don't do enough of that not
at all and i don't with sharks with
forging food i really don't like the
feeling of going out on the nat into
nature not knowing anything about how i
would sustain myself if i were there you
know you're very alienated from it and
she brings it all back yeah it's
beautiful really really wonderful nice
job jamie yukis